greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by the zip recruiter listen hiring
can be pretty time-consuming you post a
job to several online job boards only to
get tons of wrong resumes then you got
to sort out through all these resumes
just to find a few people with right
skills and experience those job sites
are overwhelm you with the wrong resumes
that's not a smart way of doing things I
tell you what the smart way to do is zip
recruited comm slash Church
unlike other job sites zip recruiter
finds qualified candidates for you and
right now the church family can try zip
recruiter for free no matter what type
of business you have biggest law at this
exclusive address zip recruit comm slash
Church if you love the show show support
and zip recruited by going the zip
recruiter dot-com slash Church CH you
are CH that zip recruiter calm slash
Church dip recruiter is the smartest way
to hire number to listen you want to
start the new year off [ __ ] tip top
module no problems this is your year
right that's how you've been telling me
for the last [ __ ] ten days 2019 is my
year I'm gonna keep snorting and smoking
and drinking and eating like a [ __ ]
gavone because it doesn't matter on the
first my job my life is changing you
want your life to change it starts at on
it right then then an app from the
shrimp export the shroom tech immune to
the [ __ ] half a brain
the signature a supplement that they
this is what made them was the Alpha
brand and to boot they give you a
hundred percent money-back guarantee if
it doesn't work for you and they don't
want the product back that's why I work
with on it because it a really deal
[ __ ] Liefeld you understand me so go to
hot calm and press in church BAM and get
ten percent off and it gets delivered to
your door start the year off on the
right foot kick this [ __ ] meal bleep
oh [ __ ]
Thursday you're sitting there with a
thumb up your ass asking yourself why
the [ __ ] am I at work today what the
[ __ ]
or why am I not at work today what the
[ __ ]
whatever your dilemma is listen Merry
Christmas poster you [ __ ] and
that's it like I said in the beginning
2019 is definitely [ __ ] here
that's the first thing I thought about
this morning like [ __ ] Christmas is
[ __ ] over we got a couple more days
of this [ __ ] and then on the seventh
it takes a couple more days people got
to talk about that [ __ ] of where
they went to Morocco and they smote Ash
with some [ __ ] Indian so nobody's
really [ __ ] full navigating till the
15th of January that [ __ ] pisses me the
[ __ ] off you know but we'll talk about
that stuff later what I really want to
talk to you about that I noticed I've
noticed for the first time this year
I've noticed it in people before but I
really didn't notice it as much as I did
this year it was like I don't know maybe
I'm getting old and you look at things
for the first time in a long time I
realized how people there's a lot of
people that don't do well over the
holidays what do you mean don't do well
they just don't do well this part of you
does not agree with them and I'm one of
those people is it like you were talking
about earlier with people aren't working
or it's just emotionally it's just
emotionally some people do not click
this time to hear they they and I was in
New York last week you know I could be
honest with you guys I was in New York
last week so I want to [ __ ] be there
I'd rather be in my [ __ ] warm house
minding my business calling a kickboxing
and [ __ ] like that I went to New York
from my family I took my wife and my
daughter and it was cold and there was
fairies to take and Monday when we took
[ __ ] sick Sobers in it but their
happiness made me happy did I give a
Frenchman's [ __ ] about Christmas not
really I mean the lights blew me away at
Saks Fifth Avenue and the tree but he
saw st. Reese's you were [ __ ] three
so it's got [ __ ] lights on it st.
Patrick's is overwhelming but my point
is this it's I don't know and I thought
about it when I was there I don't know I
don't know if it's so scumbag kids that
ruined it by telling me [ __ ] there
was no Santa I don't know if my mother
dying gave me a weird feeling about
Christmas I always just just it just
because you see some people and they're
having a great time and they wear the
[ __ ] ugly sweaters and they go to
parties and they take pictures and it's
supposed to be Joy's you've been sitting
there smoking to join these people
saying outside your door and you're like
what the [ __ ] do I do now like what what
do I do it got people singing outside my
door you open the door you're standing
like a jerk-off and you look at him and
then you give them candy a couple of
dollars here to get a dollar you'll get
a [ __ ] throat lozenger I don't know I
just never got that how has it changed
for you since you had mercy Christmases
for her but my wife will tell you
there's a couple things I hate doing
online the [ __ ] doctor but you gotta
go beyond your blood but if I tell you
what I hate the most
I hate shopping I hate shopping but I
gotta go buy clothes I go in there like
a [ __ ] hurricane I go in there I know
what size I am I know what waist I know
what jeans I want when I'm gonna [ __ ]
the tall fat store but the panga canyon
up panting wrangle Lex whatever it's 15
minutes like I know exactly what I'm
looking for I know the sections to go to
I cook I look at a couple things I go to
the section that's got the blue dots
where it's a 40% off this [ __ ] but I
know exactly what the [ __ ] I want but I
hate going Christmas shopping like I'd
rather give you the twin here go buy
yourself a [ __ ] bottle of booze leave
me the [ __ ] alone
I gotta I gotta hunt didn't rap I just
it just never I don't understand it just
never really
so growing up you're always doubting
yourself like why do I feel this way
growing up I'd be at a house and people
began going [ __ ] and all I'd want to do
is watch the foot boy you know that's
all you really want to do you're
interested for the onion dip and the
football game you know well it's kind of
sad so I thought it was just me and then
you [ __ ] go out into the world and
you bump into different people remember
having a friend in Snowmass good guy and
I didn't figure it out don't like the
third year was in Snowmass then he would
disappear around the holidays he would
disappear and just lay low and I asked
his brother he goes you didn't know this
my hanging out with him so long you
never see him over the holidays and I
thought about it you just never saw it
something happened to him when he was a
kid over the holidays and he he never
got that I get it I mean I'm gonna well
you asked me when you got here what I
was doing for New Year's I'm not a big
party guy at all so New Year's for me I
like to stay in sometimes sometimes and
sometimes he gets lonely but I've gotten
to a point where I enjoy it and I I
honestly think about well the reason why
I asked about mercy is my mom was here
for two weeks and it was great I hadn't
seen her in about a year other than a
couple days in Boston and it made me
think about you I was like I can't now
every time I see her part of me even
though I hate admitting is like I wonder
if this is the last time I'll see her
and I can't imagine what it would be
like to have holidays without without
her
so with it and whether or not like what
maybe you just don't have to get along
with your family or maybe you just don't
like people I get I don't like being
around a lot of people so for me I get
instead of being down about it I try to
be like okay well wonder why if if it's
gonna make me happy to sit at home and
watch a Three Stooges marathon on AMC
that's what then just do what I like
give yourself the gift of just being
making yourself a family right that's
where that's a good angle that's a great
angle I thought that I agree with the
identifiy is identifiy is I didn't want
to impose my same misery but not
understanding and I love I was raised
Catholic I get the effects that Jesus
was born I get all that stuff and I love
giving gifts I love all that [ __ ] just
it's not like I'm [ __ ] caught you
know singing down the streets jumping up
and down and this year I've looked
around me and I've looked at the people
around me and I told rogen when I got
back hey cuz Rogan was telling me him
and his wife were thinking about New
York or whatever and I said you know I
love New York City but for me it works
three months a year
it works in September October in April
no humidity no cold weather that price
stuff but when it comes to the holidays
New York destroys LA by a landslide
what do you mean that right now in LA
like when I got off the plane I could
tell I was in LA and the Christmas
period had just died like it just died
like in New York everything was up
lights were up people were singing
already bah bah bah bah bah bah you come
to LA and there's really nothing going
on last night when I got home or two
nights ago Christmas Eve I realized
there was a North Hollywood Christmas
parade did you know about it no I didn't
I didn't know nothing about it I didn't
know nothing about it we live right here
close to North Hollywood I didn't know
that about it so yeah I'm not blaming
anything that the main topic here is
depression over the holidays and how I
infer fact I spoke to five people who
[ __ ] that were having a [ __ ] a hard
time with the holidays there's a lot of
pressure my daddy wasn't said it he's
like Whitney even when you turn on the
TV all the movies and TV shows show
people with their families and if you
happen to not live near your family like
yeah am i doing something wrong or why
like why don't I have that and and say
yeah that's how it's hard to avoid this
hum here like we were thinking having
people over Christmas Eve I said you
know what let's just have people over
Christmas Eve
I called 15 people 12 of them we're
gonna be out of town and then I was like
I gotta think about mercy
and somebody invited this that's where
there's 30 kids right so we went that
route I wanted to spend Christmas at the
house I would have [ __ ] done it up
nicely you know but other than 15 people
I like 12 of them were gone right you
know I just don't wanna have an open
house and I have every [ __ ] body at
the house that's my nightmare
Ryan - yeah an open house anyone could
just show up yeah but I really wanted to
do that but again I called around Steve
Simone was gonna cake Quigley's no hunty
Obama was gone I mean the amount of
people who were [ __ ] gone was just
mind-boggling that's why I like LA this
time of year it says everyone believes
it's it's empty you know so that that
did bummed me out but I wanted to just
give something back so all you guys you
know I see all the time I think it was
me you and the Agostino
oh my god everybody I called that's
funny yeah and D'Agostino's from here
that's my family and he had obligations
so to bring me you your mom and the baby
the baby would have been with losing the
[ __ ] mind
at 6 o'clock at night on Christmas I
said forget it because that's all we're
down to you know and we have no family
out of it nothing like that but all
these things I mean none of these things
on the surface or even on the interior
bother me no those things it's just this
time of the year and if you know
anything about me
part of me is the board if you know
anything about me part of me is the
action especially living here
because it just dies it just dies I've
told these guys for years I shot an NFL
Pro Bowl commercial on Christmas Eve
maybe 2010 2008 work here goes late so
sometimes you catch a Ron Jack like I
caught it late Rome linear commercials
in November so to November one in
December then I caught it like a movie
things happen
you know till the [ __ ] 20th I tell
people that all the time things don't go
nowhere
things happen lately I've been looking
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] nothing's happens
like you don't know what it's like to go
on break knowing that on January 7th you
go into a set and you go on a report to
shoot three days on a [ __ ] TV show
your [ __ ] holidays are so happy
you're so happy because not a lot of
people go right into the year working
right what is the other thing about this
is like I can't it must be tough leaving
like let's say we left for these two
weeks and then you have to pay for hotel
and all that you have to buy all these
Christmas gifts and then January 1st
rent is doing your you haven't worked
for a couple of weeks and you paid all
that money like I almost take like a
take a little mini vacation in like
February or something just why why pay
all this extra money for a flight now
especially especially if the holidays
aren't that important to you go
somewhere in March do something like
that but no time buddy is important to
me the time of the year some point the
reason I'm working I have a good time
and you know I've never been a vacation
type of guy let's get it our Lord you
read the vacation type of person or your
no vacation the type of person you have
to live with these things you have to
come with this conclusion know yourself
know yourself so you don't put yourself
in bad predicaments because sometimes we
pick a partner who wants to be [ __ ]
Julie McCoy and she's a travel direct
and every week they want to do something
and you know what the beginning because
you'd want to get in their pants
you agree this [ __ ] but throughout the
year that they'll pay you like every
three months we need to take a trip and
now you're caught up in this [ __ ] I'm
going to these and for some people they
really enjoy that and I'm not knocking
that at all
I've just never been a vacation I like a
relaxing McKay even more stand-up comedy
your your relaxation is just sitting at
home and not moving
exactly so tell yeah yes yeah yeah so
what's the difference
there's no vacation for you I'm talking
about people who go away and actually
like let that mind go and have a great
time I don't qualify I don't qualify and
you're right if I do go on a vacation I
don't like that much movement I don't
like that much much movement I enjoy
Disneyland because I was on the site you
know I enjoy when I go to Huntington
Beach because I'm on the site you know
20 people have hit me up and asked me if
I'm going to UFC on Saturday yeah and
they got a better chance of seeing
[ __ ] Muhammad Gandhi there because if
I got a listen I won't drive downtown
for [ __ ] dick do you understand me my
I [ __ ] hate going downtown
try me test me like Hollywood's bad
enough Marina del Rey is bad enough
Woodland Hills see if you ever see my
Cuban ass downtown
I wouldn't [ __ ] go downtown if you
paid me I get lost every time I go
downtown you just go down there get lost
so I wouldn't go to a fight I went to
one fight there was the biggest mistake
because you leave with 18 to I can't do
I like the fights I got spoiled with Joe
we would go right from the Mandalay Bay
upstairs right downstairs right I love
that [ __ ] I gotta leave once I got to
leave the facility and you got a far
ride you're in no danger
plus it takes a while to get out of the
parking lot I can't imagine you know
it's it's people think like what tough I
met a guy on a plane a couple of months
ago maybe a month ago or something
he's a man of here I travel a lot if
he's lonely and you want to come over to
my
I said what do you live like he told me
go in contrast to the show where as he
goes about 45 minutes in ilysm you got a
better chance of hanging yourself a
pulled overboard ain't this and he was
like really and I go yeah and then I
think last week or the week before you
guys retweeted Chris D'Elia
all right great I love that that was the
best and you know guys you look at that
clip and you go there's something wrong
with D'Elia I look at that clip and I go
that's me and there was a clip of D'Elia
basically just saying when people call
them up to and ask them to do [ __ ] you
want to play flag football you know you
wanna you want to go to either the best
pancake I don't think so you know stand
on line and get breakfast and not really
do you want them I'm the same person I
don't know what I want to do till I want
to do it I feel bad for people people
call me up or time bands you know do
something let me know okay I don't know
what I'm gonna do anything I'm gonna do
it if I call you up and you say to me
I'll be there in 40 minutes
you lost that's why I don't call nobody
know cuz I'm ready to go oh yeah I'm
ready to go that's why I fly solo when
this finger does this and you're with me
in this finger does this that means I'm
about to turn my back I'm gonna start
walking well that's why I get nervous
when I go with you to shows cuz I'm a
you see I don't leave me after the way
you stopped
you [ __ ] up I will get that colleague
of it I have left tons of people at
different places this finger means wrap
it up we'll leave it once you see this
shoulder go across like bela lugosi like
what he puts this cape on you're in no
danger seeing me stop I go deaf I don't
hear nothing Joey Joe I don't know
nothing I get to that car I pop it open
I get in that car I don't know I don't
know what I want to do till I want to do
it I felt really bad I have a friend in
Jersey and he can't call me man let me
know when you gonna do something
I'll make your 40 minutes away by the
time you get here
I've done it roll the joint and watch
the episode of [ __ ] knuckles right so
that's why I don't like that when I'm
sitting there now and I get that first
burst of hunger I start thinking about
what places I want to go to and I start
thinking about who would I call to go to
those places you never accept Mexican
food maybe the sushi days with me had
done you embarrass me
ah generic white sushi okay because see
this is why I was with you until this
point who cares what the other person
then he wants to go to Japan now the
[ __ ] American sushi I would try
something there yeah you would try
something now yes madam because like I
eat Turin shrimp and different
variations of always out who cares
[ __ ] shrimp shrimp is delicious how
bad to go get the same [ __ ] you get
everywhere wishes shrimp salad shrimp
toast I read the the main [ __ ] thing
so they could slice it and put it on a
piece of rice and it still tastes
delicious no it doesn't do like [ __ ]
usually put wasabi on it I don't okay I
do absolutely post I'll be on how dare
you I do
he just gets mad you're an embarrassment
not taking you for sushi even the way
looks I mean those would you find this
[ __ ] mud to Sousou sushi tuna and
[ __ ] shrimp like a [ __ ] it's
delicious Hank get the [ __ ] that is well
you gotta get those the roles that I do
get roles blue crab rolls destruction
rolls the [ __ ] eyeball rolls getting
all those rolls
[ __ ] people trying to get whatever
but you know like the death thing really
bothers me because I thought I could
tell you even before my mother died I
wasn't hip on the Christmas thing
I was hip on it because I knew my mom
was gonna give me an envelope beside
that I wasn't hip on it like I didn't
give a [ __ ] once I found out there was
no Santa I just lost it I think it was
the no Santa thing I don't know who told
me because my mom for about 2 or 3 years
ad me [ __ ] confused
she had me on the ropes guys my mom was
that good and I watched like a hawk and
when you watch him like a hawk and they
[ __ ] you you can't my mother was good
from the ages of 5 to like 8 she hadn't
even after people told me there was a
[ __ ] Santa Claus and I confronted her
she still [ __ ] my [ __ ] up I looked all
over that house for gifts and the tank
in the basement I looked everywhere I
couldn't find it I went to the bar with
her I came back the gifts under the
[ __ ] tree till this day I never liked
before she died never really asked them
because I kind of liked the [ __ ]
thought of there being a Santa yeah
if s I mean I grew up the only always
thinking as if one of her friends
slipped in and bring ussen and then slip
back out that's still awakened but I
would watch her like a hawk all those
Christmas she is that she was alive then
once I found that I think you were
[ __ ] wanted watch but I would watch
like a [ __ ] hawk if she was wrong to
the store what she would bring when
she'd come back I would look through the
receipts like oh Jesus I couldn't find
the [ __ ] thing and then Christmas
[ __ ] Eve there's 20 gifts so that's
what I think [ __ ] me up once I [ __ ]
them once that scumbag
on the corner told me there wasn't a
Santa it must have crushed everything I
had inside as a kid there's that I
always hated getting like for holiday
stuff like you have to get ready and it
got forbidden to your house you have to
help help your mom get ready and set the
table and I used to hate that stuff that
was and then and then there's always
like a couple people out the parties
that you don't like and then spend your
time avoiding them that was what got me
everywhere I go there's something I
don't like so I'm used to that [ __ ]
except you Jitsu and she like that but
just it just
bothers me that because I know I'm not
alone I know I spoke to a few people and
I thought I was the only one that had it
and I faked the funk for years and then
over the years I've heard people mention
little things under their breath like I
can't wait till it's over you know and
even in the Netflix special I talk about
the first year without having my mother
that I think back at that and it's
traumatized like it's it's amazing that
I made it through that holiday patch
especially that young if it wasn't for
the drugs and my stupidity maybe I would
have been dead I don't [ __ ] know but
I know that first year when I think back
to it when I was writing that joke and I
thought about Gina and I remember just
thinking about that first year without
her it was like anything else in my life
like it was like going to prison and
thinking about not having we'd ever
again nothing happened
life went on like you always think
something Bad's gonna happen like when I
got set it's I'm like hum I gotta make
it in there without weed
I don't need Chinese food I don't need
this but I'm always gonna need weed next
thing you know I just smoke weed for six
months and I was doing well you know you
always think how you're gonna make it
and that's that first holiday without
that loved one it's gotta be one of the
roughest [ __ ] patches in your life
and it starts you get that nut in your
stomach two days before Thanksgiving
doesn't even bother you you think about
it but you put it under the carpet and
then two days before Thanksgiving you
get that [ __ ] nut and then
Thanksgiving you realize that person's
not at the table that is terrible
that is horrible when you realize that
that person is not at the table and then
go to bed that night you're a little bum
but you wake up the next day and there's
[ __ ] Christmas everywhere but chill
numb to it you're immune to it you got
immune to it at the [ __ ] Thanksgiving
table and you go through the motions and
you smile with your girlfriend or your
wife but at the end of the day you're
like I have something can't wait for
this [ __ ] the holiday to be over I
don't know why Christmas is that holiday
and listen you know there's a lot of
ways to seek help you call a friend
there's suicide hotlines this just
people to talk to but my go-to people
are my friends man well I'm feeling that
way and sometimes you don't have to tell
them you don't have to call your friends
and say you're feeling shitty just call
on somebody and then talking to you for
four or five minutes about generalities
unravels things you don't have to call
me Oh Joey Etta I feel like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I miss my mommy oh I mean I'll
accept that but I'd rather you call me
and talk to me about something else and
unravel your mind that way because
that's what I usually do well I'm a
little stuck I'll call somebody I'll
call him [ __ ] at 2:00 in the
morning and I'll unravel with him and
then if he gets to the core of it then
I'll tell him like I have a friend Mike
Duffy that I've known since Colorado
I've known him since grammar school
really his family his father I met his
father before I know him we've been
talking about the last couple days
because we're both hurting over a friend
he's hurting over his son going into the
army and he's all alone you know and
it's ugly to be 59 and to be all alone
in y'all you know a lot of people going
through some rough stuff right now
another dear friend of mine lost his
parent this year he's going through some
[ __ ] you know I saw a dear friend we
have a dear friend that's going through
some stuff right now he lost his dad
about two Christmases ago and I see it
and this year like two of them three
people and I'm not spoken to because I
just remembered this topic just [ __ ]
you know I thought about it when I was
in New York a lot about it because I was
back in my neighborhood the one they
were going to the Metropolitan Museum of
Art and we were supposed to turn in 86th
Street I told the captain who were
driving to turn on 88th Street instead
so I could see my old building and I saw
the Christmas holidays
but I saw the Christmas holidays on
Amsterdam and as I went to the Met was
when I started thinking about it how if
it wasn't for my wife and daughter New
York it really just been another day for
me but since I had my wife and daughter
in the car and they were happy you know
you should have seen my daughter's face
at the [ __ ] Radio City Music Hall now
when I go to that thing on my own with
my wife [ __ ] no [ __ ] no but even my wife
just to see the smile on her face
while she was holding the baby up and
the baby would sit next to me and then
she would go back and then I passed out
for two [ __ ] hours I fell asleep at
the Radio City Music Hall Rockettes sure
you know embarrassed I wasn't when I
woke that's what dads do oh my god I put
the three big glasses on and just passed
the [ __ ] out but just doing that the
next day of going to New York and
walking around and that's when all those
memories came back to me that like I
stood looking over the tree with my
friends being in like 13 and eighth
grade and lying to my mom and telling my
mom that we're gonna go somewhere and we
take the bus over go to the Rockefeller
Center go see the tree and there'd be a
bunch of kids singer than me and my
friends just at doing Lily's [ __ ]
Mambo singing like you know like I would
think to myself not really my friend as
much as I would cuz I never felt that I
never felt the joy the [ __ ] want to
sing you know like I don't have that
so I'm just trying to say is that listen
man if you don't feel it through the
holidays you're not alone for years I
felt that I was the only person that was
going through this and it made me feel
[ __ ] terrible inside like it made you
feel like a Scrooge you're not a Scrooge
you're just not a [ __ ] holiday person
and something must have happened you
know what happened which makes you know
I always tell people one of your parents
died or somebody close to you died
sometimes in life it's like taking salt
out of your food it's like you still
eating food every day but it's not salty
it doesn't have that flavor to it that's
what happens that's what happens when
you lose a loved one and a holiday comes
that holiday isn't the same because so I
get all that [ __ ] but what I'm trying to
explain to you people is not to feel bad
that you're not [ __ ] Elvis Presley
jumping up and down for joy it's normal
you don't have to go see a psychiatrist
you don't have to go see anything you
just I because trust me I beat myself up
over this for [ __ ] years and I can't
tell you how many Christmases I was
doing well that I just fell asleep like
I couldn't wait for the holiday because
I knew I could sleep for two or three
days and then I would get revved up
again for New Year's Eve and I'd be
ready to go like I had no I thought I'm
ready for this [ __ ] year to start
like I'm ready to [ __ ] god want
Oxnard to be over to Oxnard tomorrow
Friday and Saturday tonight Friday and
Saturday and then [ __ ] that's it and
then I got a whole week of waiting you
got a whole week cuz this town ain't
doing nothin til Wednesday which is the
second right yeah absolutely not
nothing's happening so for a guy like me
yeah I got [ __ ] to do like a rat I wrote
today I went to digital into the private
my man Vinny I can do it [ __ ] but it's
not the type of action like when I all
my other actions are shut down we just
still do the podcast which is greater
than we could have taken off we took off
last week we could have taken off but no
I wanted somebody especially this [ __ ]
this topic where people are feeling this
right now still and they don't listen to
this podcast and go oh I was I thought I
was the only one that felt that way no I
did this podcast because I wanted you to
know that you're not alone there's no
chemical imbalance there's no nothing
some people like broccoli some people
don't you know the other day we came in
the house with his mom and they were
kind enough to stop the Johnsons right
and get cupcakes or something yeah and I
saw we open up a cupcake I never saw
anything like that in my life it was the
neatest cupcake if you looked at Lee you
totally had a [ __ ] lobster tail in
front of me with a piece of [ __ ] next
to it on the side I watched the whole
cupcake go down but he did it so
politely like he had a paper towel under
it he had a plan for this cupcake then
he took the wrapper off the cupcake very
meticulously he didn't want to mess up
the frosting and if I'm correct I think
even used the fork absolutely that's how
much it was as meticulous as I've ever
seen anybody you know really I hate
there's nothing I hate more and this is
why I think the fly thing bothers me I
might not be super organized but I hate
like getting sticky or getting stuff on
my ID it drives me bananas so the
thought of getting a lot of frosting on
it I thought especially your house like
not my house I could wipe it off or go
wash my hands but it's somewhere
somewhere else in front of Hannah breath
now I it
my mom has a joke that when I was a kid
she could leave me on a towel outside
because I didn't like the feeling of
grass on my like it was like it was
prickly so I I don't I don't like all
that I don't like frosting arm yeah
I I don't go getting your wings out
because I can't imagine how it like very
rarely I hate himself yeah wings out
like if you go out go to like Buffalo
Wild Wings or a place to go
the only place I've got our wings with
you is that place and I think was Austin
the hotel had really good wings but if
you look I feel like 18 napkins in front
of me because there's no way I'm leaving
out on my face especially around my mom
and then your wife and daughter you
don't wanna make an ass of yourself so
you making a see yourself doing
everything else my god what's the
difference between [ __ ] Merry Christmas
what do maternity eating a cupcake like
it's the last [ __ ] steak on earth my
point was that the way you look at the
deck cupcake I think it will [ __ ] buy
the cupcake I don't give a [ __ ] about
cupcakes but the way you look at that
cupcake you my business absolutely you
ripped two things off you caught it with
a fork you to me I would just eat the
cupcake into [ __ ] bites cause I'm
gonna leave my like so that's why I'm
trying to say we beat ourselves up too
much we beat ourselves up too much and
you're talking to the king of beat
himself up nobody beats themselves up
more than I do that's why I smoked a
weed I smoked a weed so I could think
about what I did to the [ __ ]
precision and then beat myself up along
the [ __ ] way why did this why I said
that's the reason why I smoke weed weed
keeps me in check it always has and
always will be it plays the tape back it
makes me remember what I did why I did
it and what made me [ __ ] do it so
this is what I'm just trying to say to
you people that again the holidays are
not for you that's fine they don't have
to be there is a holiday that's for you
maybe you go [ __ ] bananas during the
4th of July
maybe you feel like marching there
Martin Luther King Day I don't [ __ ]
know but that's the whole point of this
[ __ ] podcast like that and something
else the thing that might make my dick
hard today was that Sunday Christmas Eve
I
go to the other side of the town and I
stopped in CVS and I got my [ __ ] day
planner for 2019 and I got my notebook
for 2019 even though I didn't need it
and it's so weird that to me right now
today it's 2019 and I'll tell you
something if you want to get anything
accomplished next year you should be
playing right now like it's 2019 already
right now you're shooting pool you're
putting the balls you're setting up the
field for your 2019 to be easier I
already started right my goals 2019
I already started figure out how I
wanted to do things I talked to the book
agent told him where I was you know I'm
already setting up like lead dance no
telling what I did today I talked to a
few agents today I mean I am the type of
guy that in my mind it's 2019 I want
everybody to know that you ain't gonna
wait to the 15th of the month when
you're [ __ ] with me we go right to
work Wednesday the 2nd right to work we
go right to work like nothing happened
there's nothing I could do before that
nothing you do you're just gonna be
calling an empty [ __ ] phone I bumped
into somebody the other night some girl
at the Comedy Store something that she
was asked me if I know who won the job I
go now is not the time of year and then
she goes alone office of trying to get
an agent I go again now is not the time
of the year she goes well I'm gonna go
out on Thursday and put on a bunch and
whoops I gonna who a bunch of dead
people they're not coming back to the
7th and the topple off mentally they're
not gonna be there till you have to
imagine the 10th or the 11th there's not
gonna be no mental you're still thinking
about the holidays and what you spent
and flying back and your kid got sick
and your cat vomited and you know see
you have so many [ __ ] things that are
on your mind this part this different
parts of the year where you're thinking
of things for me I'm not doing anything
but I am doing something I'm setting up
my year I am setting up my year and this
is the same thing
I'm no smarter than you [ __ ] guys
this is the same thing
you [ __ ] should be doing yet
tomorrow you have work Friday you have
work start thinking about this at work
start thinking about this tomorrow
instead of watching TV go for a walk
take a pad and a piece of pen Liat and
figure out what things you want to do
next [ __ ] what things are you sick and
[ __ ] tired they're not doing that you
need to [ __ ] do already I've been on
it like already I'm starting to do this
[ __ ] alright I told you nobody beats
themselves up more than I do
last night I got up at 4:00 in the
[ __ ] morning I stayed up for about 35
minutes I got so high I had to go right
back to bed I'm not gonna lie but I got
some tremendous [ __ ] we they take a
picture of it tonight I got so [ __ ]
high last night I went back to bed to
eight the morning I went to bed about
ten last night
damn that is good weed quarterly ten I
was out [ __ ] cold and I got up at
four wide awake with a thousand things
to write I got up I peed I made a
[ __ ] cup of coffee I thought I was
gonna have to stay up I'm just gonna
stay up and go to jujitsu at eleven with
Vinny and dog I wasn't the back of smoke
this [ __ ] weed and I got so high I'm
like oh my god even with the coffee I
gotta go back to bed and I went back on
that bedroom I put my head down and my
heart was beating like ah I'm not gonna
fall see messing I opened up there was
seven fifty eight and I'm like I like it
I got a [ __ ] couple of hours in me
I'm rested but like when I woke up and
looked over what I wrote and it was my
goals like personal goals weight goals
comedy Gold's you know like all that
timing I started writing down like
comedy for example you know I want to do
20 weeks and I want to shoot a special
and I want to write something different
for a special and I started writing down
what things I had to do to do that write
an hour a day get on stage five times a
week you know I put down that I want to
go down into 65
that's 21 pounds you know I wrote how am
I gonna do that by watching my points by
being careful with the edibles and
smoking weed and going crazy at night
with the [ __ ] munchies I've pretty
much little by little lemonade
everything out of the house at night
late night except for the [ __ ]
two-point jumbo puddings those jell-o
pudding those are 2 points I could eat
those all [ __ ] bad but I can eat two
of those I'm [ __ ] good and nobody
gets that feeling started carpet Cosby
gets a nickel you know and everybody's
already can buy [ __ ] Visine for his
glossy eyeballs nothing we could [ __ ]
try to rape somebody in prison that poor
best and yeah if you're not getting your
to 19 and order your [ __ ] slips you
really are like you should have your
notebook you should already just start
writing down if you want to go to
college what you want to do while you're
in college with things you want to look
at anybody can write that gold sound
this is I what I learned from writing
goes out that anybody can write yeah I
wanted Mercedes but how are you gonna
get a Mercedes yeah I want a new wife
how are you gonna get a new wife once
you write that how out that's where the
power comes from it's like when you lift
weights you don't lift weights you don't
gain strength from the push it's from
the pull back from how you resist it's
the same thing with goals
when you write your goals down I love
when people send me goals and they're
like I want to do this I want to be an
astronaut I want to make a million
dollars you know tell me how you make a
million dollars what is your plan if you
write it out to the [ __ ] P as crazy
as it sounds I swear to God as crazy as
this [ __ ] sounds when it happens you
will go back and look over this thing
and it won't be exactly how you said it
was gonna happen but it'll be pretty
[ __ ] close because a man without a
plan is not a man so write it out you
know I wrote out that I want to do a
loose special I wanted to be sensual
around the story and then jokes coming
from that story if I'm a good
storyteller I gotta utilize these things
and it was so weird how already from
doing I didn't write the story yet I
wanted to say anything but from writing
out the story and the way I want to
attack it I filled out like
three-quarters of the page you're gonna
notice that you your own mind they'll
tell you what you already know years ago
I told you everybody buys an iPhone and
an iPad you I have the answers to your
[ __ ] problems you just don't want to
[ __ ] look at them and be honest with
yourself that's for being grounded
really really comes in you have to look
at yourself and go these are my [ __ ]
shortcomings and there's nothing I can
do about it these are my shortcomings
and there's nothing I can do about it
what am I gonna do well I can either let
them be shortcomings or I could work on
them and they're still gonna be
shortcomings but they're gonna be a
little stronger and that's what I did
this year with a lot of different
situations and for some reasons for some
things that worked for me
after some things it did it's me being
as grounded as I can number one I have
you guys to keep me in check number two
I talked to my friends at home every
[ __ ] day they keep being checked I
never want to forget about who the [ __ ]
your hand and if I'm slipping I should
know because of the results when you're
slipping you know because the results
you're getting I did three spots I
stayed on stage for two weeks I went on
stage Saturday which is the [ __ ]
disaster and I want on stage twice
Sunday they were both disasters the
timing was off the jokes were off
everything was [ __ ] off I know this
so yes that night when I got home Sunday
obviously I went to the drawing board a
little bit but Monday Christmas II
wasn't I really realized the mistakes I
had made and there was nothing you need
to do it was called the ring rust
and laziness that's what happened it was
ring rust and laziness not lazy because
I didn't get on stage you should always
give it a breather especially it would
stand up especially after you've gotten
through a long stretch to get rid of the
bad mistakes you're doing when I was a
basketball player I had a bad mistake I
used to do I would grab the rebound and
then throw it down and then go up when
you grab a rebound you don't put the
ball down you go right back up with it
so for years I made this horrible
mistake
sometimes on stage you make mistakes you
stick on to a clock saying you shouldn't
be saying there's something in your
jokes that you shouldn't be saying I
promised myself that when I went to New
York I was going to look old my jokes
and rewrite them get rid of the Terry
Crews stuff you get a new clothes or
when I went back to New York between not
feeling well and always being on the
move I didn't really have a chance to
look over it when I got back I looked
over it for two days but it was a
sufficient time to go onstage and
prepare my mainly excuse for myself I'm
telling you the reason is why I fell I
know what I fell onstage and I try to
correct it so when I go on from the big
stages like this we got an Oxnard I'm
[ __ ] prepared for that a lot of
people can't deal with that a lot of
people don't like when people say
something tell about them me I'm the
type of person I don't like somebody to
say something me about it I should feel
it I should know it I should see what
the [ __ ] is going on so this is just a
couple things just to get you to
nineteen started if life hasn't been
going your way maybe start taking some
advice maybe start asking people for
help you know you know just because it
works for fuckingly
doesn't mean it's gonna work for you
just because it works for Joey Diaz
doesn't mean it's gonna work for you
just because it means it works for you
doesn't mean it's gonna work for Joey
Diaz but I will tell you one thing that
works constantly that's writing down you
go
and that's yearly quarterly and monthly
and if you really want to push it go
weekly I do all four I do what I want
from the year and I look back and what I
wanted from this year and let me tell
you something I got everything except
two guest spots on TV shows I went for
four
I got two so I was halfway there you
know I looked at how many times I
auditioned I didn't even have the
opportunity to [ __ ] booked two other
ones cuz I only wanna have like three
other [ __ ] shows or year I only went
on seven auditions [ __ ] compared to what
ten years ago
240 Wow
and I'm going with three theatrical
audition is a week and two commercial
auditions a week so now I'm going with
twelve theatrical right and [ __ ]
ain't commercials so I would I would I
would do twenty auditions a month from
1997 to 2007 that was pretty much the
[ __ ] that was pretty much it
especially for a guy like me especially
after The Sopranos how many [ __ ]
opportunities opened up I went on seven
[ __ ] auditions this year unless
something changes the next four [ __ ]
days unless you guys know I got two
movies or two movies off it to me thank
you very much the people who offered
them to me but there were movies that
were both out of state and I had already
prior [ __ ] commitments but that's how
slow the TV movie business has been for
me but I put four guest stars on four
different shows and I got to I put a
special down I put on 20 weeks of work
down and I put the right 30 new minutes
of material I'd get all
some do you put the ones that you messed
on next year uh lecture is next year
next year I want something different
okay
so for next year I want something
different no you never tagged on make
sure you want a different set of [ __ ]
goals every year is something different
and it's I want you to when you're
writing your goals yeah you want life
goals and you want success goals well
I'll tell you what's the pages that
should be even bigger
is your personal goals weight attitude
you know all that [ __ ] that goes in
there with it I started doing that one
about ten years ago
well maybe about seven years ago and I
started lightening up I could feel my
life lightening up a little bit once I
started writing because it's important
it's important to know the stress it's
important to notice pressure it's
important to notice unhappiness it's
important to know there's so many things
as they touch your life so you don't
absorb them do you file on the same fear
frustration with your job you you ever
have a job and you want to work early
every day and you know you know what man
I want a promotion and also some guy
comes in he's got a college degree and
he gets the promotion
that's frustration you know what quit
your [ __ ] job because they already
touched you with frustration it's gonna
grow inside of you you're gonna continue
to go to that job see that boy see that
guy yeah he might get fine then you
might get the job but they didn't want
to give you the job in the first place
so you don't really want to be that
situation is like that when things touch
you that's it because if they touch you
and you feel that it's only gonna get
worse for you you don't want happiness
you know uneasiness if you're stressed
out by a job like you [ __ ] they're 80
hours a week and they don't tell you
what to do and you know they want
results all those little things they
take away from your [ __ ] who you are
you don't know it and you don't see that
twenty and thirty near that I I see it
now I see how happy I am now that once I
notice it then that can stick up and you
either could proceed or step back if you
proceed you're gonna get the same
results you always got the rest of your
[ __ ] life if you step back you might
lose a little bit of money you might
lose a little bit of [ __ ] work but
you know what you gain peace of mind and
you gain three years on your [ __ ]
life
which is the most important if I contain
at the end of the freckle you know it's
so weird well I this is why again it's a
joke but I [ __ ] hated that whole
thing of thirty years ago because thirty
years ago if you would ask me my goals
the first one I would write down would
be money money money money money money I
wanted money I wanted money I didn't
have a reason why I want it I didn't
know how I was gonna make it
I just the number one thing would be
money not to keep up with the Joneses so
I could do coke and drive a Testarossa
and about fifteen years ago I found the
happiness in life and even though me and
my wife lived in a one-bedroom apartment
with six cats and the apartments now I
kept this we had air conditioner we had
cable TV we have a microwave the
refrigerator was always filled with food
and that's the first time I gained real
happiness in my life on my own and I
still remember sitting on that god we
should not even have a couch what's that
[ __ ] the futon
we had a futon like broke we had a crazy
Gullu put two by twelves and you know it
was like Ralphie's Ralphie broke
everybody's futon no in town Oh
everybody everybody had a futon and
Brockett Ralphie broke it from
the guy that opens this little doors up
to us the boxer but I still gotta get on
the podcast Medina so there was such
Gavin Boyd's he broke Gavin boys it's
[ __ ] whatever he broke somebody
else's he broke like three or four those
[ __ ] oh my god
from that futon in Hollywood that was
the first time I haven't looked around
we had an apartment bro there was an
earthquake the walls but there was an
earthquake once when I was in that
building I like to hear that Rick's
hitting each other it was the scariest
building in the world it's hell they
retrofitted it but all we need is a 3.5
earthquake and that buildings going down
it didn't matter
I remember sitting on the couch or one
of the cats at that time I was doing
coke I was still doing coke well I'm a
mama saying you know what I'm a lot
happier now than when I was ten years
ago and I don't have three-quarters of
the [ __ ] I want but I had a girlfriend
that cared for me I had these cats that
I loved and I had a semi little comedy
career going on at the Comedy Store I
was working I was acting I was like [ __ ]
I just shot this with James Coburn I
just did this you know I was happy and
there was no money there was no money
there was maybe 80 bucks in an ATM
account and my wife had six or seven
hundred functioning dollars for the
house that you know if we wrote a check
we would bounce it just like anybody
else in America you know just think
anybody else in America
you know so it's just really weird that
I remember going wow I have $80 in the
checking account and I have a checking
account
life ain't that bad and this whole time
I thought I needed a million dollars you
don't you don't I'd rather you have a
job that you enjoy three people that you
like around you a home that suits your
needs you know
yeah everybody wants a house for the
[ __ ] but low light your cigarettes
and you could walk around naked this 15
chicks hanging upside down with that
mouth open that's all great and [ __ ]
dandy but how many of us could really
get that none of us so we get the
bedroom we got whatever the [ __ ] we want
and that's happiness it's not half this
[ __ ] there with you right now you're
young and you're thinking this guy
drives this and this guy drives down
listen doesn't really [ __ ] matter
what you drive at the end because when
you're in that [ __ ] casket do you
think they gonna sit around you and go
he drove a [ __ ] Lamborghini always
like no they're all gonna sit around you
don't want to put past all you are for
drinking milk and he got a heart attack
[ __ ] somebody on viagra over another
[ __ ] you thought I was dumb and that's
it and that's that man that's what I
wanted to talk about I wanted to talk
about the feelings that we get around
this time of the year and how for years
I felt shitty about them and at the end
of the day they don't matter it's just
not your cup of tea and I wanted to talk
about prepping for the next year if you
want your [ __ ] prepping you're
slipping so please once you listen to
this podcast before the weekend starts
you've been having some rough times in
your life maybe the UOP always maybe
your [ __ ] animal died maybe a loved
one died maybe you got five maybe you
have to switch careers you know what
write yourself out of this chair you
don't need to be Hemingway
trust me I'm no [ __ ] Hemingway I've
written myself on these jams by just
sitting down being honest with that
notebook hey if you scan this I hide
this is notebooks I have it no book I
have a [ __ ] that I just write in there
from time to time I want one person to
find it my wife won't know how to find
that she doesn't know about it but
she'll know how to find it and I told
her about it so when she finds it she's
you know exactly what it is is it like a
diary no it's I know bleep I write to my
daughter
oh okay it's a book that I write to
mercy I try to write there three times a
week
I like compare our lives you know tell
how strong she is how well she's doing I
tried to tell her while I was the world
of my age at that life you know I try to
tell different things so she never feels
like I feel growing up something happens
to my favor I want her to know who I was
through my own words you know just
something from watch the sons of anarchy
you know he has a great idea my copy
from Sons aniket thought it was a great
idea
the way that you really know you don't
hear nothing you you get to read it
thoughts
reading some of these thoughts are very
important you know social media social
meeting if you this time as I write
what's in my heart on the social media
but this time is I really can't because
people lose their [ __ ] minds
is it hard to be that honest with with
the notebook no you have to be honest
with something you have to be honest
with something like I said I have the
hidden notebook I'm gonna have like two
other notebooks and I'm honest with all
three of those notebooks because
otherwise I can't work out with them
soon no will no work when I get home
from that sense when I get home at night
there's one more page I write in my
notebook and that's how my day went
I might work out one time the podcast
went where I want the podcast to go you
know I ate too much fish for dinner but
at least you're getting it on paper
nothing is more powerful than the
[ __ ] pen the power of the pen and
I'll sit here 200 podcast here and I'll
tell people at the pen
is the end of all their [ __ ] problems
because it was the end of all my
problems
nothing really moved forward until I
started writing and once I started
writing about the past and reading it
then I really launched then I really
took off and I did and I'm not the dog I
took no writing classes in college I
took nothing I don't know nothing I know
how to tell a story but telling a story
and writing a story or two different
[ __ ] things so this times I write
like I talked and I wake up the next
morning and it's [ __ ] three pages of
garbage because I write like I talk I
could writing a story and telling a
story there's two different [ __ ]
things but writing the truth is a
[ __ ] huge thing on a piece of paper
about how you did about a certain
behavior about something you said about
a lie you're told once you clear it up
on paper somebody's gonna find that
someday somebody might not find that
someday it doesn't matter you came clean
coming clean is good for the soul come
and clean is good to move ahead and come
and clean is phenomenal for comedy
because you empty all that [ __ ] out of
the head because once you tend to become
a comedian it's like me every day I
sprinkle [ __ ] grass seeds in yet and
you gotta figure out what works for you
and what doesn't
if not you'll die Obama's right which
you die of anyway you know I did the
same thing but this teaches you how to
die less bombings by having a notebook
you know like I said the artists way
years ago 20 years ago it was a big hot
book there and I asked somebody when it
was this is when you wake up in the
morning right get a blank piece of paper
write your thoughts up write all that
babble out of your head I had been doing
it already I'm like I can't believe
that I've been doing what they
recommended here and it works
honestly it's time it sounds like the
reason why I like therapy just to get
those thoughts out of your head and
you're able to do it just and then in a
different way like either do you ever
speak it when you're writing it or it's
all you're all not very quiet at all in
my head sometimes I'll be laying down
sometimes I'll be in a conversation
thinking about how I'm gonna write it or
sometimes I'll be in the room with my
wife watching the TV show and we should
be focusing on the show but I'm thinking
about how I'm gonna write this thing
down that I just thought about and where
it's gonna be placed how do you feel if
you don't get to do this generally I'll
feel irritated for a few days until I
get that because sometimes I just get
caught up in the moment like everything
else not forget to write it and it's
like having a joke before you go to
sleep at night and thinking that you're
gonna remember right in the morning
there's no worse feeling than laughing
in bed at 2:00 in the morning and going
[ __ ] let me turn it oh I didn't write
this down and go that [ __ ] was
so funny I remember what the [ __ ] I said
in the morning
and when you wake up in the morning
listen I'll give you $2,000 remember
[ __ ] unless you ride it the [ __ ] down or
tell somebody now I just get up and
write it down because I've lost so many
wars oh but not getting up and writing a
stupid joke or just writing a key word
from the joke or something you know hey
whatever how about a [ __ ] whatever
floats your boat man we're all different
in I do this podcast to let you know
it's okay to be [ __ ] up it's not okay
to be [ __ ] up and live in [ __ ]
denial it's okay to be [ __ ] up and say
you know what I'm [ __ ] up
I got good days and I got bad days like
everybody else that's why I do this
[ __ ] podcast just like you guys but
you're all [ __ ] put a pants on one
leg at a time and we all believe when we
get
cut so that's it that's that it's a
church or what's happening now in a
Thursday afternoon if you're not doing
anything tonight tomorrow or Saturday
night myself Lee and the flame and
[ __ ] gay fireball of debt Eric Rocha
will be [ __ ] kicking ass up there up
at the [ __ ] levity live knocks I
that's if you're not doing nothing right
if he got plans you know me you got a
living level of I'll catch the next time
I do a lot of spots around town but if
you ain't doing dick and you're bored
and you want to smell some reefer and
see how some [ __ ] savages live
whether you live in Taurus and a Barbara
Tapatio what Phaedo Beach were you like
peas no babies no Beach come on down
[ __ ] will be sparking we're doing
the whole [ __ ] thing I'm bringing
some special edibles for leaving up
these 500 milligram [ __ ] brownies
like a leak - [ __ ] there is stronger
than death you understand man he's the
one that George Gainey
don't worry about gave it to me no names
in this naming no names you never say no
[ __ ] names don't worry about who gave
it to you we just got him they just
appeared and we got my ten mortar we got
anybody in the weekend you understand me
perfect so dumb restful weekend was
splitting every night 500 hard well
going deeper than deep old-school you
understand because everyone saw I gave
up the edibles but this edibles reason
me I gotta be honest unless I gave up
edibles for a three-month stand I ate a
piece of Boston it was terrible and then
they need him again and then George
showed up with these brownies one man on
the way Laura what happened to no names
no names
George showed up no mames and he gave me
this the sat in the closet
and one that was sick there's like nine
30s I'm gonna bite a bit off I've been a
bit off I got so [ __ ] up and I gave it
away I gave it to a friend of mine he
told me the next make sure my song is
like Jesus Christ retardant in those
things and I'm like they are pretty
fantastic I was at one of my closet and
found another one
and then my men dropped five off on me
the other day I had to give one to my
buddy you gotta paint a vague
- my game - to my other buddy and I kept
- and then last night he came up my man
dropped off a [ __ ] box to make sure
we're covered for [ __ ] oxnard so
there's no misunderstandings in
understand me thank goodness we wouldn't
want that to happen maybe I will CB deal
in there
I pull the likes or something with your
little piece tonight I know I was
clutching at some point you did
something yeah you're gonna get it cat
damn I gotta take the channel don't even
ask what I gave you even if you don't
for the drug test myself they won't find
that it won't be in there but yo we'll
be back Monday New Year's Eve ready to
say bon voyage - 2009 - 18 it was a good
year you got you out you got a friend
then you got us man we got each other
before we [ __ ] check out of here
you know me dawg I don't care what size
business you got whether it's small big
10 employees 12 employees 20 employees
hiring employees is tough you know and
you gotta be smart with it where you
gonna get you employ from job boards
that send you candidates that aren't
qualified for the road you posted on job
boards that send your mouth I stack of
resumes to sort through or job boards
that make you wait for the right people
to apply for your job you know listen
you know what smart is the smart is
going to zip recruiting calm / church to
hire the right person unless unlike most
other job sites zip recruiter finds
qualified candidates for you it's a
powerful matching technology that scans
thousands of resumes to identify people
with the right skills education and
experience and actively invites them to
apply to your specific job so you get
the qualified candidates mucho rapido
that means fast because time is money
you know that as a business owner that's
why zip recruit is rated number one
by employers in the US and this rating
comes from hiring sites on trust parlour
with over a thousand reviews you
understand on the front SAT you post a
job on several online job boards you get
nothing you get nothing then you gotta
sort through the resumes you get nothing
and you get the wrong resume the zip
recruiter comm slash Church that's the
way to go understand me that technology
is the best and right now the church
family I'm gonna get your zip recruiter
for free
you're like Joey how could this be I
have a small business I only got four
people got free zip recruiter for free
go to zip recruit accom slash Church CH
you are CH if you love this show and you
want to support us and help us out and
help yourself by getting a tremendous
employee go to zip recruiter dot-com
slash shirts that CH you are CH that zip
recruiter dot-com slash Church we're
just talking about you getting your
[ __ ] life together it's 2019 when is
it gonna [ __ ] end and this goes for me
too you understand me I get my little
slipping points tell them I gotta lie to
you because I do it every other month to
give my brain that alpha brain is the
way to go right you're [ __ ] goes down
get your [ __ ] alpha brainless and
alpha brain is so good it's on its
flagship supplement it's so good they
believe with it that if you get out for
brain and they don't help you out you've
got a hundred percent money-back
guarantee you you keep the [ __ ] pills
okay one of the company does that tell
me nobody go down to calm right now
surprises Church baby and get 10% off
deliver right to the crib right there no
drama no no nothing and I'm not talking
about just supplements I'm talking about
kettlebells weighted vest I'm talking
about club bats I'm talking about shroom
tech sport shroom tech immune I'm
talking about tremendous protein I'm
talking about things that will change
your life go to adam.com right now press
in church
and get 10% off your first order
delivered right to your door I wanna
thank zip recruiter dot-com / Church and
haunted doctor I'm / Church for
sponsoring the church what's happening
now but most importantly I want to thank
you guys for having my back have at
least back and that's it and that's that
it's [ __ ] Thursday go out there sling
some dick do it over the weekend so you
mind your business on New Year's Eve and
you don't get stabbed in the [ __ ]
kidney all right nobody wants to spend
the second the third the [ __ ] January
when rent is due in the [ __ ] hospital
because you want to go to the stupid
party get your [ __ ] load job this
weekend and mind your business we'll be
back Monday morning New Year's [ __ ]
Eve 6 a.m. ready a rock tip top take
this [ __ ] muley
[Music]